Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA and NCAA analyst he called
Michigan and Florida State on Saturday
Thursday called a.m. Michigan Florida
State and Gonzaga this year's final four
national title game can be seen
exclusively on TBS reg by the way back
to his NBA duties thunder at the spurs
this their hey you're gonna be in San
Antonio I am gonna be in San Antonio on
Wednesday work Thursday but I leave
Friday morning in you door but we're
there Thursday and Friday you are there
Thursday yeah we're gonna be there
Wednesday I think where are you gonna be
in relations River where Riverwalk
I might have to swing by Thursday
morning I got a hoop welcome to come on
the show yes yes we can cut I joined you
Houston Houston was it yeah yeah we got
yeah I've got to make it come on now I
know and you know we got the hoop there
we had the hoop in Houston by the way
there's like to see reg and what are you
now 50 rent 51 to do yeah I mean he was
shooting from three-point range and it
didn't take you long to get back on the
bike there and I went my god I did it I
don't know when it'll ever leave you do
you know if you'll never leave your shop
will never leave you I think I'll be
able to shoot when I'm 70 just because
I've been doing it my whole career but
that's the last thing to ever leave a
true marksman as their marksman alright
let me ask you about the end of the
Florida State game against Michigan
Leonard Hamilton when he talked to Dana
Jacobson really didn't seem like he was
aware of how many points they were down
you guys were saying why why aren't you
fouling here like what happened at the
end of that game number one you always
try to extend the game I think some of
the mistakes down the stretch for
Florida State as well as coach Hamilton
he used old he burned a lot of time outs
early so they didn't have any timeouts
going down the stretch which obviously
you need to kind of keep one in the bank
just for situational purposes
so they ran out of timeouts and I
thought coach Hamilton was really just
caught up in the moment they were only
down by four and I said look I know a
guy who scored eight points in nine
seconds anything is possible
there was 11 seconds left and you extend
the game no matter what because the way
Michigan if you remember we're shooting
free throws down the stretch
the Seminoles had a shot ya know a lot
of luck needed to happen for them but
they still they still had a shot so you
want to try to always succeed in the
game I just thought it was such a
hard-fought game for the Seminoles and
they blew so many opportunities to to
actually win that ballgame he was
shell-shocked and he was out of it and I
think the questions were fair from Dana
yeah and I just think he was spent and
the frustration came out you could
understand that people need to
understand in the heat of the motion
this is as far as coach Hamilton and
Florida State has gone no one even
expected him to be there and they had a
true shot to move on to the Final Four
and it was disappointing so I give them
a little bit of leash for that but it
was the heat of the most heat at the
moment and the emotions coming through
but there were fair questions because
you always extend the game no matter
what the situation is would you rather
have the tournament UMBC had beating
Virginia the first 16 to do so or the
run that loyal to Chicago is on well you
asked this last week yeah and now I
switch because last week I said you NBC
because you will forever and in revenue
by now that you've made it to the final
floor because you always reveal to the
final four teams you remember the winner
but this has been a special run for the
Ramblers and sister Jean so right now
I'm leaning more towards Lola's Chicago
because there's still work to be done
for them
how does Loyola beat Michigan look it's
a lot closer than what people are gonna
are probably saying right now they play
a style and the good thing that Michigan
has going for them their last two teams
will have faced them or low love Chicago
Texas A&M and Florida State because they
play very much similar style they like
to get up and down they have a lot of
shooters they have that great length as
Texas A&M at Florida State but this is
going to be it's funny that this is in
San Antonio this is going to be a
shootout at the Alamo yeah one of those
games where there's going to be a lot of
threes transition defense is going to be
paramount for both teams and who can
take away threes Florida State when I
say they were kicking themselves the way
Michigan shot the basketball I believe
they were four of 18 for that game and
they were like two of 12 in the first
half and they were down one that was a
missed opportunity for Florida State
they should have been up seven eight
points going into the second half a
little bit of a cushion the way Michigan
was shooting the basketball and you know
with vlog they're really struggling from
the field they should have been up
you've got to be able to take the threes
away from Michigan if you want to be
able to win
Duke bounced out and they're probably
going to have five of the first 25 picks
in in the draft how did that happen I
will give credit to Kansas but is it
they one and done mentality here that
you know you got to sort of strike
strike gold and you got to do it in a
you know interesting timeframe here well
we saw Coach Cal have success with that
with the young players and the one in
Duns look it's it's a unique situation I
mean because Kansas has experienced
players that are tournament tested I'm
not going to knock it and say it was
four freshmen and a senior the reason
why they lost they lost to a better team
Kansas they made plays when they had to
Duke had an opportunity to win that
ballgame in regulation and shot by alum
goes in and out
so no it has nothing to do with the one
in Dunn's and you know being a young
team the better team want and I don't
know if the better team won not Duke was
the better team
well they shoot it by yes yes yes
I got a Kansas big man who you know gets
in found trouble fouls out I got to
lottery picks big man I mean I got a
dominate that I just I was really
surprised
I don't know that Duke never got into a
rhythm and once again I'm giving credit
to Kansas I just looked at that Duke
team and as you said what did you say
last week about them they were the 31st
NBA team the way the two games that we
saw absolutely the size look they had
the size obviously the pedigree of Coach
K but I mean they're young too I mean
it's all about experience as well that
Kansas team and the knocks they took
last last year in this tournament we
called their games last year and
everyone was expected him to get to the
Final Four and they were up ended I
believe by Oregon right yeah so you
learn from your mistakes
he's the Hall of Famer from Turner
Sports Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the
third he's got the Thunder at the Spurs
Thursday night at 8:00 do you think that
they sent you there just because we were
going to be there because nobody really
cares about the Thunder at the Spurs
right did you request this game did you
say let me Tonio with my guys that's the
most important thing I was also
wondering about this wrench what would
the odds be of getting the fab 5 back
together
for the final four as Michigan okay
Loyola has sister Jeanne if the Fab five
show up behind the bench what are the
odds of Jalen and C Webb sitting down
together can I say negative
point zero point zero percent of that
can be happy okay would that be awesome
absolutely but I'm not quite sure
everyone is playing kumbaya and holding
hands in a circle and wanting to sit
behind the Wolverine [ __ ] how about I
get four of the Fab five 85 to 90 of
that happening and you know Ray
Jackson's not doing anything so he'll be
available Oh people under the bus just
know what Ray's doing right now oh my
bad my bad
come on I just have a little fun do you
think see webs underrated as a
ballplayer yeah I think he's a Hall of
Fame type player yes and I know he's up
for it but absolutely people forget this
year he was ahead of the time what we're
seeing from big men today being able to
stretch to the floor and pass and shoot
threes and play with her back to the
basket see what was that player and he
was when you think of the Fab five as
much as I love jaylen you don't think a
jail in you didn't know if you Webb see
Webb was a bad dude his freshman year
you know when they little man when they
went up against Duke I mean that was
that was real I mean it was that was on
number one see Webb was the size that he
is now in eighth grade see what has been
playing like this for a while yeah he
just had bad teams right yeah but yet he
had his run in in Sacramento he had his
moments him the Lakers and blah day and
you know Bobby Jackson and those guys
maybe they had Doug Christie they had
they had their opportunity and all you
want is an opportunity why is it you
weren't he would never talk about dating
Tyra Banks do you remember that
[Laughter]
I was dating Tyra Banks like why would I
hide that
right so if you were dating Heidi Klum
you would be like yes I would have a PA
system I'd have somebody walking with me
with a megaphone you know and just
announce it man loose lips come on man
come on man you gotta be close all
certain things oh really
yeah come on man no she doesn't want to
hear all that hey I didn't want to hear
all that I think she doesn't want to
hear all that
no no tyrant wasn't known as Tyra back
then when he was she was dating Chris
Webber yeah like like she was a handful
of the black supermodels come on now she
was she was pretty big back then
now when you date it like you never told
anybody you dated times you can beat
Steph Curry one on one right now can't
you do we keep our podcast do we keep
these conversations yeah we talked about
in October November and I said
absolutely Golden State is gonna win
back-to-back championships yes it was
the one thing I said
barring major injury to me this is major
injury yes between all of them being
hurt like limping to the finish line
literally there is a real opportunity
seriously for Houston and I'll even
throw Toronto in there now if these guys
don't get back - I don't know 95% of
their regular form there is an
opportunity for teams to win the
championship to me it's back to being
wide open okay but if I said I'll give
you Golden State or the field I'm taking
the field now okay now I'm back to
taking the field the start of the year
when you talk to me when I said 100%
yeah Lari major injury Golden State was
gonna win back-to-back championship I'm
taking the field now I'm back to taking
the field because there's too much going
on too much going on did you ever
fracture you know the klay Thompson
injury did because I you know it's one
thing to get injured and then healing
and then he's got to come back and get
ready to be able to play
in some important games here soon one
thing I do not know is his shooting here
yeah yeah come on now the good thing you
won't lose a lot of conditioning because
they'll still be able to run I'm sure
he's running with the team he's doing
drills like that yeah but I mean this is
your shooting here this is your guide
hand yeah I mean then you know you got
the knee and then you've got the
ailments to KD to draymond know who's
supposed to be back or came back last
game there's just a lot going on
what's Golden State and you know her
already telling people that Steph is
going to be out the whole first round
I'm taking the field okay as much as I
love the firepower I'm back to the field
all right when do you get in on
Wednesday Wednesday evening about five
or six okay all right well let me know
if you want to do dinner but Thursday
morning we're gonna pencil you in and
you know me I am gonna I think I'm going
to show up I said yes but you should
have I mean yeah you should
it'd be great full uniform coming
through have poly or free the address
you know I'm rolling through now I think
guys why don't you wear your UCLA
uniform I am gonna be representing UCLA
if I come through okay but your old
college uniform would be great you're
she's got it she's got it framed there
it's probably as you walk in your house
come on what did you wait what did you
weigh your senior year at UCLA 167 okay
I won 161 did you really yeah maybe come
on very light we will
see ya maybe Wednesday and certainly
Thursday I love you guys can't wait to
see you
that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the
third for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]